Lenny Dykstra former baseball outfielder
remember the 86 World Champion Mets his
book is house and nails the memoir of
life on the edge the construction
demolition the resurrection now
available online wherever books are sold
nails good to see you again all right
now yeah yeah good to you uh soon as
Lenny came in the studio and he goes
remember last time we were face to face
I said China Club Chicago you had a dip
yeah had a cigarette and a drink in your
hand believe it right it yeah yeah and
your with your brother I'm yeah I really
do remember that it's a couple other
people joining us later
did you did you party more with the
Phillies of the Mets oh I mean that's
not even I mean I don't even know
partying other than that I mean like
that whole mess scene that's made out to
be some big like crazy wild group is I
mean our Phillies know like we they look
like like children yeah
oh come on I mean like I mean like
people needed a prescription filled ID
fill at form yeah I mean we were just
all it was is I mean I was a crazy team
the Mets team was a great team because
of like the you know the curtain calls
and excitement and this is is this kind
of now like I don't see it out there
anymore I don't see people celebrating
they don't seem like they're having fun
so we had fun and you know made people
kind of like it you know well but if you
looked at yet booze you had drugs
whatever in with the Phillies I mean it
was only a constant party I was
everything man it was rocket ship the
roids and and any other team knew too
you know
I mean they want to know part know part
of us and we were on a mission you know
I mean we were I mean that was a again I
got to play for New York and
Philadelphia and playing in the to like
best sports city then went in both of
them yeah I mean that's uh that's just a
that's a gift you know
the toughest thing to write about in
this book was what well probably what I
did to my family probably I hurt my
family where does that stand now I was
great I have a great great relationship
with my kids and even my ex-wife but I
talked to my kids every day you know
like Luke's in a ball actually for the
Atlanta Braves and I sent like 320 so um
fortunately for me my relationship with
my kids always has been saved saved
great what was the easiest thing to talk
about
all right well baseball I mean I come as
easy but women drive but what kind of
were you doing drugs when you played a
lot like what well I didn't start it out
what's kind of what's kind of funny
about that is it's not funny but so I
was a leadoff hitter and when I was at
Matt's remember the Mets when I was a
mess I didn't take a drug I didn't
notice where it was I you know over the
kid but see when you when you play every
day and he played hard won seats are
like twenty eight nine your body your
speed up so you know I would see my
teammates like Kruk and all these guys
drinking like 20 beers uh the games take
their pain away and you know I'm kind of
a like cut through and clarify kind of
guy I like to kind of Eva
you know first one to the to dance so I
asked a trainer I said there's got to be
something else you can give me two dozen
to take the pain away and gave me a pill
it was a little white pill and one drink
and like I thought I'd reinvented the
wheel I mean it was a pill a vicodin
okay yeah I mean so and it works by the
way I mean so remember I let off so take
that made more sense than 20 beers yeah
I mean like you know I thought like I
got him again
these guys they don't get it and you
know in this world in life there's
really nothing for free so I paid it
like heavy price for that but it did get
me on the field every day and I did some
things that here that
actually no one else is ever done but
when did you start using steroids Oh
ninety yeah oh so not with the Mets oh
come on I mean I mean the Messiah yeah I
was a part-time player with the Miller I
mean more than part time I played a 400
bats but it wasn't till I got traded and
became the everyday centerfielder that I
didn't really forget how to hit I just
like my body couldn't hold up I'm a very
little I'm a small guy I mean and so you
thought throwing pet amis on top of that
and I mean at the end of the season like
I mean I my baths all your telephone
pole so I I kind of took charge that
myself I was way ahead of the curve on
that because of when I got traded from
Philadelphia I mean from New York to
Philadelphia the general manager Lee
Thomas said hey don't worry about 8990
here you're not going to line up you'll
be in line up every day so can you hit
325 I think that first year in Philly
didn't yeah well the first year I got on
the [ __ ] yeah other stuff I mean yeah
sorry about that
yeah I took on the but you knew right
away there was a big difference with why
I did it but I did it for I mean as bad
as this weird this might sound I
actually did it for the right reasons I
did it for my family and for my ability
to stay on the field because I just
physically am NOT built to withstand the
162 game schedule and understand
something like people the public they
don't really get how grueling and how
tough of a schedule it is and and
baseball is not baseball in pro ball
it's different it's the whole test of
the mind and the body and a lot of
things involved but you also I mean you
got to be fair to the other players who
may not have been using like you said
you did it for yourself only one don't
worry they're stupid I mean that's they
don't like money but how prevalent that
was everyone do everybody yeah everybody
everybody on the Phillies using
anybody that played well I mean the ruck
I mean is it a coincidence that the year
I had I'm leaning I meant in 400 in jail
I'm leading the league and everything
and I mean I had 325 elite league in
hits I mean why how could I leave the
league in hits I mean there's only one
person in the world I can lead bleeding
heads right and I did it twice and I
couldn't have done that without the
proper medication now am i proud to say
that no but the schedule is so grueling
it's so tough that as a guy having like
like for instance today drugs are out of
the game
but when I was playing like what do you
do what a guy like you look next to him
and he's like built like a you know
Greek statue let him make 30 million
you're gonna go home and get a real job
yeah but you had some guys who you know
John Kruk didn't look like he used to oh
yeah Curt Schilling didn't look like he
used her own pitchers out not a lot of
pitchers did but Darren Daulton looked
like our pete incavilgia look like they
could have been yeah Anke he was
allergic to leather you know inky yeah
he was allergic to leather leather man
he was like you couldn't play defense
right oh okay yeah he's really really
allergic to leather but he's a vet
actually the best five o'clock hitter
ever played with I mean he could hit
some batting practice oh yeah people
would go watching chameleons just
apologize yeah and then it would be 7:05
and then all of a sudden well then you
know you put a little this curveball
slider yeah that's the hardest part of
the game the book is house of nails a
memoir of life on the edge the
construction the demolition the
resurrection now available online
wherever books are sold
let's take a break because there's a lot
more to get to here I got to talk about
you know financial what happened going
to jail Charlie Sheen I mean there's a
whole lot here to talk about yeah I mean
I hope you have like a week okay yeah
but no what would the one thing we'll
talk about is that that book is um I'm
proud of that
and I think that the people that read
that book will understand that you know
it's happy it's sad it'll make you laugh
will make you cry but at the end of the
day it's entertainment I mean did you
feel guilty taking anybody down in this
like you take anybody down let some of
these Davey Johnson you were pretty
tough I mean I'll take him down tell him
right now is he it was under
underachiever and over overrated manager
I mean he but you talk about him
drinking I if I wasn't being like cranky
and maybe his best friend was like you
know jack has been Daniels
I mean he's and he's a player's manager
meaning my never talked to you he's
always hung over meaning but you don't
have to put that in the book why not but
it look I makes for good reason why I
put that in the book is because the
truth number one that's all books about
the truth and number two three people
from the organization told me that he
spots for me and he wasn't trying want
me to be traded which is all BS he's one
behind it and look where let him I mean
let him like I mean it set the mess out
on a on a downward spiral you guys
should have one more that team was too
good I mean look I mean at the end of
the day I mean he has a great record but
he had great players but even the World
Series we won took the baseball gods
from Meredith on it right no I mean only
one that cuz a manager on that side
screwed up your relationship with
Charlie Sheen how does that start when
do you meet him well I mean Charlie
Sheen I we were we were best friends for
a long time
started in 93 when I was on a mission
and like dominating and the Phillies
were dominating I got a note in the
clubhouse saying Charlie Sheen wanted me
so I went actually as a good chapter in
the book about it and I talked about
because the Oh Charlie could play
baseball actually he was pretty good so
when he hitting his batting cage and so
sorry 93 and unfortunately and did kind
of when all this no bad news have but
you would go to his house and get high
with Charlie no
you did not get it no you saw him get
high not but I got him off the drugs
yeah I didn't I
I saw him during the day more there's
more business I helped him with business
more I liked probably fired 15 people
that were stealing from him I was
probably umpteen I probably was the only
person every up paid a dime and want to
die I was his friend you know but you
talk about there's a room that you
didn't even know existed where you had
to punch in a code to go into Charlie's
private yeah that was then well what
happened was uh the fiance at the time
she uh I didn't know we're really in she
was she she called me and said service I
have someone was crying the top of their
lungs I like what he talked with he who
is this if she said you know I met you
at Charlie's and I said what he called
me for said Charlie been you know holed
up and smoking whatever and I said well
what'd he call me we said everyone tells
me you're the only one I can get will
get him off but he'll listen to so
anyway that's what led to it and but
when she said you'll never find him I
said where's he gonna she said he won't
find him I said what are you talking
about I've been over two thousand times
and it's like right out of the hell
Alfred Hitchcock movie meaning like he
had to like punch a code in this
bookcase when and so what was in the
room oh it's not funny but it was like
it was I tried to break the ice because
oh there's Charlie was his uh you know
the pipe and the phone and I said look I
got to tell you man if if you're gonna
smoke crack least you smoked in the best
crack this is the best crack room I've
ever seen
no I had like his Babe Ruth like bat and
all of his sports memorabilia I just
unbelievable you know just awesome stuff
and but anyway I'm in this kind of a
difficult situation to talk about though
because I'm no charlie overall he's
really a when he's sober he's a humble
great guy
triple smart triple smart just a lot of
bad people around them you know and and
they would try to get rid of me too
because they knew that I was going to
execute them which I did you know it got
rid of him
yeah how many times have you been
arrested I think once I don't know well
well I don't know I mean I got arrested
what
well there was there was like I got
detained for I don't know why and then
they said that bankruptcy fraud
so that was indicted though grand theft
auto yeah that's uh that's so all I can
say about that is to read the book yeah
um because again I don't want to sit
here and like tell you tell the people
what's right what's wrong with the facts
will tell you and when you read the book
it's all there and all they're all out
of the readers judge if the grand theft
auto was was as much as much as me being
a centerfielder for the Mets tonight
meaning again no but I'm not going to
sit here and make excuses in like how I
let the book speak for it and you know
the legal chapters in the book like you
know one of them's called I fought the
law and the law won you know I mean the
bottom line is is uh you know I've made
a lot of mistakes and a lot of things
I'm not proud of but did I do something
that that should have put me in musician
where the United States of America took
took my freedom away for as long as they
did how long were you in prison over two
years what was that experience like um
it was uh it wasn't it was that it was
hard his hardest thing I ever did but a
lot of things happen in prison - you
know I mean well I mean I had a I got
assaulted by deputies L got arrested
though even in LA County Jail so they're
whisking take me out to the ballgame one
night and I said they don't want to hear
it tonight and so
but anyway so they're making fun of you
that you're in prison don't take me out
to the ballgame yeah the kind stuff but
like I said people that's another thing
that's online the FBI the same group
that put me in prison for selling
furniture the same group that prosecuted
and put them in prison so they took
everyone down from the bottom to the top
including the sheriff how did you lose
it all it felt like you had everything
there was it all a house of cards here
was it real uh yeah I was as real as
real good but when I see what he's had
lost at all I mean we had Wayne
Gretzky's house you were making money
stock tips yeah
car washes I mean it felt like whoa look
what would happen with me is um I
actually became kind of too successful
meaning I didn't really like lose any of
my businesses I mean what I mean is I
didn't get stupid overnight I mean but
maybe I put myself in position to you
know when in 2018 the whole world came
crashing down so do you have any money
now um I mean the federal government's
got most of it we got 50 million from me
but it's okay money's not the same money
doesn't money isn't that's probably what
I learned more than anything in prison
is like money became kind of my drug and
and so it was never enough and so I
talked about in the book that I mean I
got some some clarity in prison and and
it made me realize what was important
what's not important and like I used to
think that because I was home with my
kids I bought them stuff that I was a
good dad but I wasn't really present you
know you know I was thinking about the
next deal or this or that you're trying
to make up for the fact that you're not
there by buying him things well no I was
there no I'm saying when I was there I
wasn't there because I was like no
always planning the next caper skiing or
the next
you know no way to get more and more and
more and sometimes you know it's uh look
money's not a bad thing we all needed to
live but I think when you do something
for the love of money just like the
baseball gods come and get you when you
think you got baseball figured out kinda
lowlife gods come get you and with me
they they got you in a big way
the book is house and nails it's a
memoir life on the edge the construction
demolition and the resurrection now
available online wherever books are sold
yeah it's great ceiling yeah and the
book by the way has this brighter he's
kind of famous named Stephen King who
who makes a comment over read the book
and said that uh that the book was a sad
me I'm happy and he said it was
strangely beautiful and one of the best
sports auto buyers I've ever read so
Stephen King said that in a Red Sox fan
to you cut his heart out in eighty six
so and then he had Jack Nicholson on the
back of the book saying nails nailed it
so kind of the same thing but like I
challenge people to to to read that book
and fines and tell me that that book
whether you love me or don't love me or
hate me and whatever it doesn't matter
the book is uh
I mean I poured out my I mean it was a
it was a six month ordeal that I think
the hardest thing I ever did well good
luck with it Lennox the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience